(African violin music)
- [Sudan] There's like a strong
violin culture in Africa as a whole.
Being able to see the violin culture
in all of these different ways.
It just resonated with me
because I am African-American,
and I know that my African
roots are from somewhere.
It just opened up my whole mind
to the idea of violin, and
like what you can do with it.
("Come Meh Way" plays)
My name is Sudan Archives,
and I am a singer, song writer, producer,
and violinist from Cincinnati, Ohio.
My songs are all about textures.
It's just one idea with all of these ways
to get different sounds.
My songs usually start with my violin.
And then once I find like
a idea on the violin,
I usually have like my
loop station with me.
I'm able to just add more
layers and more layers
and more layers to that.
I can pitch the octave down.
I can just make it sound like an accordion
or wind instruments.
Being able to have technology is probably
why I'm able to like be a solo artist,
because I wouldn't be able to do
all of these things at once.
(intense violin ending)
This is my song "Nont For
Sale" off my EP "Sink"
♪ This is my light, don't block the sun ♪
♪ This is my seat, can't you tell ♪
To start a song I usually
start with violin.
The whole format of "Nont For Sale"
is just this simple violin riff.
(violin riff plays)
The style of the plucking
came from like my fiddle background.
All the other melodic parts
are basically variations of that riff.
My parents raised us in like
this strict church environment.
("Wake Up" plays)
My biological dad is a preacher
like we had to read bible verses
and write pages about them.
My step dad, he was a music producer.
He really wanted me to pursue music.
He just really pushed like
the creative side of me.
Baroque Violin Shop is
a store in Cincinnati.
Hi!
- Good to see you again.
- Good to see you too!
- What do we got?
- I first got into violin
because the owner at
Baroque Violin Shop came to my school
and played the cello, played the violin,
and had like this really
cool story with it.
But also like using loop
stations and effect pedals.
That was when I was like,
OK, I need to get a violin.
(Sudan plays violin)
I'd still be making donuts
and waitressing or something
or in school maybe,
if I didn't keep playing violin
and like keep experimenting.
But the thing was, it wasn't
that I'd played violin,
it was like seeing you
and seeing these different
kinds of violin players.
Because not just orchestra
settings like seeing a band...
- Their all important.
It's really, it's music,
it's not (voice fades)
- We really couldn't even
afford violin lessons.
My mom suggested that I play
with the choir at my church.
There was no other like
violinist up there.
So then I eventually
developed a sense of ear.
When someone just says anything,
I'm able to like play the same thing.
(Sudan plays violin)
There's kind of only
three parts to the song,
which is violin, bass, and drums.
Whatever riff I'm playing,
one of those notes
is gonna be the bass line.
(violin bass riff)
All the other parts of the
song, that aside from violin,
are just kind of like simple variations
to just kind of amplify it.
Definitely like the drums like
if I wanna be like boom clap
(rhythmic beat on violin)
(violin riff and bass)
And the bass on the verse
it was an electric bass.
But on the pre hood, it changes into
this sub electronic bass.
(electronic bass beat)
I create all of those
ideas with the violin.
And then I just kinda like
follow the lead of the violin
with other electronic
instruments in the computer.
- Lord, we thank you for this food
that we're about to receive
for the nourishment of our bodies,
in Christ name we pray, Amen.
- Amen.
I never really liked my name Brittney,
and I was like "Momma
I don't like my name."
She was like "what about Sudan?"
So I started going by Sudan,
actually my mom, everyone,
just calls me Sudan.
Mmmm
- Isn't it good?
- Mhmm.
One day I just decided to just
check out the music in Sudan.
And I found all of this really cool music.
And there's like a strong violin culture
in Sudan specifically, but
also in Africa as a whole.
("Nyun Taa Jilma" plays)
I changed it to Sudan Archives
because of this like ethnomusicologist.
She specifically like studies
like west African fiddling.
And their playing all these
crazy like inharmonics
and all this stuff with just one string.
("Nyun Taa Jilma" fades)
There was like never really any other
black people playing violin.
So, when I saw like people
in Africa playing it
that looked like me, that
makes me feel really good
for some reason.
Maybe I'm not an outcast.
("Oatmeal" plays)
Once I changed my name to Sudan Archives,
it just kind of started to click.
It kind of made me want
to keep practicing violin
because there's so many
different ways you can play it.
You shouldn't think about it so hard,
it's just self expression.
I was like OK, there's no
excuse to not keep going;
you can literally teach yourself
or make up your own style.
The lyrics are kind of self explanatory,
but I was feeling a little,
you know, used at the time.
It was like mainly just about
like close relationships,
but then it's like a bigger picture to it.
The whole moral of it is just
like knowing your self-worth.
♪ This is my light, don't block the sun ♪
♪ This is my seat, can't you tell ♪
♪ This is my time, don't waste it up ♪
♪ This is my land, nont for sale ♪
You can't buy me, you can't sell me,
you can't trade me, you can't
be me (dismissive laugh),
so stop hating.
The word "nont", came from
a sign I saw in Ghana.
It was like a big piece of land,
and I was like "what is that sign?"
And they were like,
"Oh it's just someone bought the land
"and they're just saying
its nont for sale."
So I was like "Oh, that's lit!"
It's like an ode to my
first trip to Africa.
And that was my first plane
ride out the country as well,
so now I have that memory forever.
(Nont For Sale plays)
♪ This is my time, don't waste it up ♪
♪ This is my land, nont for sale ♪
♪ Eh eh eh eh eh eh eh eh
eh eh eh eh eh eh eh eh eh ♪
(music fades)
A lot of people say like
when they see me on stage,
by myself, triggering
everything, multitasking,
doing it all, it's
something inspiring to them.
I hope that it can inspire people
to do that in their own
way whatever they're doing.
I wanna create new ideas with my music.
(violin playing fades)